Another common question we get is, how long should we wait before you kill or stop a campaign?
So this is assuming that you've set up your ad correctly, that you did the proper due
diligence and you selected the right city and the right niche.
So assuming that those things are correct.
Remember that when we set up an ad campaign, the first two days is a policy review and
then the first five days after that is called a learning, it's in its learning phase.
So the first seven days of a new campaign is never really the best results that you're
wanting to get because Google is learning your ad.
So at a bare minimum, we say at least 14 days because that gives you at least one week of
landing your ads where they should be starting to land and you can start making any tweaks
and stuff like that.
For most of us that do this, we let our ads run from beginning to maybe when we're going
to pull it for three to four weeks after launch date because we like to have two full
weeks of running the ads out of the learning and the policy review phase.